[Music]
in 3 2
action so good good good
[Music]
good bad anyone but him I didn't approve
him you know that you are literally the
last person on Earth I want to see it
slapped the out of you I really
could and I'm open to that in a safer
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stun gu
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to keep it super profes profes
is my middle name you said your middle
name was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster there it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back B Jody's movie is dead why me
you're a stump man nobody's going to
notice you that's your job no offense
I'm I mean some taking you find Ryder
save Jody's film you get the love of
your life back I'm not the hero I'm just
a double not today you're
not Tom we need you back on set
[Music]
pal oh
dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail he
was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
Jason board
they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you
making you yeah made it it's too
dangerous got to be stairs go go
what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love how BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core yeah
boy what you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy Margarita
make some bad decisions yes
oh the heart and you're
[Applause]
to when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories
not
Memories new
things I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day hey come on get your stuff let's
go
let's try that
[Music]
again a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who are
running out of it until one
moment chain
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're
living but I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want from
me
New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you why who are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she died
wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day
do you have no idea what those girls
have
come I think he can see into the future
are he's trying to change what
happens will you get
down why aren't you scared of me why do
you care for me your future was almost
so
different if you want to live you have
to trust
me get
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
little
we all know anything can happen out
there sometimes we feel
lost we push and we suffer we keep going
that makes all the
difference hey what happened to you boy
you don't look so good meatball look
somebody likes my meatballs hey Paw
Patrol we got a race to win just
remember Michael this race doesn't
Define you I raced for 19 years this is
my last chance to win three 2 1 there's
a young boy living in the city all do
was over the next 10 days these athletes
will cross 400 mil climbing biking and
kaying that dot is Daddy go Daddy
D let's talk get the meatball 3 days 200
miles ago leave the stupid dog and let's
go come on move dumb dog what is it boy
oh oh God can't believe I almost walked
right off that Cliff extra meatballs for
you my
friend he's hurting what do you think he
went through before he met us whatever
it was it wasn't good how the hell did
he get all the way from here to there
while we were on bikes and zip lines and
running and climbing he must have wings
we don't know about boy you know I'm
back like I never left you want to try
to erase the buckets of pain I need a
bigger bucket team BR rail has traveled
over 200 miles and they found a
companion Daddy has a dog what if you
done think you found your new partner in
suffering Michael yeah he's the king I
think we should call him Arthur Arthur
the
king how's he doing he's been through so
much this B needs a vet I don't want you
to hurt
anymore he's a
fighter just like
you famous dog looks even worse than the
rest of you maybe you all deserve each
other always underestimated aren't my
buddy this isn't the route on the map
it's okay just follow Arthur lead the
way
[Music]
King I've never seen anything like this
everybody knows
[Music]
about guess what I'm not a dog
person
for most of human
civilization we believed that life could
only
exist on the surface of our
planet what else were we wrong about
welcome to my
world what you come on
in this world has more
secret than we could possibly imagine
mirac
I
still now and
[Music]
then what is
that that's not
Kong who could have done
this
Kong can't stop this on his
own he won't be
alone
welcome to
my is that a mini
Kong
whatever you have to
do however long it
takes promise me you'll find your way
home
furiosa give me this
promise
[Music]
L and
gentlemen start your
engines
I'm fous the darkest of
Angels the quest
is do you have it in you to make it
[Music]
Epic
oh
oh hi there little buddy
[Music]
you hungry little
guy you want a little
[Music]
more and that's how I adopted John okay
now have you ever been with a plate
don't eat please no ow it's so hot it's
really hurting ow you deserve
[Music]
to say when never John bury me and
cheese oh I apologize in advance the
eating you're about to see will not be
pretty and if you have young children
this would be a good time for them to
leave the room you never SE
nobody hey Junior This is fck my father
you ever jumped a train I've never
jumped here's I stop really
where oh OD you think he'd see that
coming let's get it I deserve to
be oh hey Dan
happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size four rest huh how you so big look
at the big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
down up on a six sorry about the mess
hold
on oh hey Bo hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy God we're going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip oh St collaborate and listen with a
new 5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in a
car can someone unlock the car
please call right
everybody I want to
found what was that little pothole
Maxi's been up the whole time by the
way wish
that before I met your mom I was a
covert assassin I skap at life and now
they found
us what the
being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us look at you playing the family man
I'm not playing this my
life hey I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait
wait
new
[Music]
[Applause]
record I'm telling you it's going to be
another hot one out there in fact there
are heat alerts in effect for New Jersey
feeling like
[Music]
100°
my
what is
that
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear guts freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
oh hell
no move hey PG-13
please what was that Lord is the queen
be Regina George don't look her in the
ey you could be really hot if you change
like everything I
met welcome to health and human sexual
reality we will be getting into
abstinence of course Then followed by in
the spring condoms and choking you're
learning things now that I don't know
how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet baby
ew we as women have to be able to
support each other get in loser welcome
Katie you're never going to believe what
I found this morning you're burn book
mom go make snacks for sure for sure
Regina
yeah do you like gum sure oh no I don't
have any I was just you're a mess we
will help you
caddy why are you dressed so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
that is shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay all we've done is to make Regina
hotter and revive the wet look dance
break
who wrote all this
[Music]
junk K pushed her Regina really should
be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't see it
like a face
breast incorrect you have to pick a
French name Chanel No Shel no beon
see
scared
do we all as do kiss no he didn't when
we were fixing up the pool
stop they said it hadn't been used in 15
years maybe they weren't cool
people this is not now for the
camps used to be scared of
pools cider come on
cider get a Vibe here do you have a
boyfriend no hey someone's coming over
in a
minute your shut
Marco you need to say something
back Ronin
Marco
why aren't you saying
anything my kids have seen things and
I'm worried something is happening to my
husband Dad I've been looking for
you
there has to be some way to stop this
[Music]
marot
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little n
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
Oompa Lumpa an OA what now in fact in
Lumpa land I am regarded as something of
a Whopper they call me lofty sorry
ladies and gentlemen greetings to you
all my name is Willie won you see I'm
something of a magician prepare to be
amazed
T inventor may I present Willy Walker's
wild and wonderful wishy-washy WKA
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
ooh he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send Wonka
a message do not sell chocolet in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head I love a bonk on the
head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
Buddhist give them the old one
too I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course
run away every good thing in this world
started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world
not in
PRI good night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke you quite
viciously with a cocktail
[Music]
stick hey head of the wedding of my
sister yes I am so where's your fiance
wait is this him hey I'm Ben I was for
hall pass on your break wow you are a
child it's a pretty long flight do you
want anything from the front of the boat
I'm all good on Creatine and smelled
like insecurity nothing small about me
what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this
girl's a disaster
[Applause]
we're going to ruin our wedding
sorry is it going stranger what's going
on over there they dated she crushed his
heart that man does not have a heart no
way honey look who's here who is that my
ex Jonathan my parents have been trying
to get us back together he's like a son
to us maybe we should just tell everyone
we're together what it would solve that
problem for me and you clearly want
Margaret she seizure with me she wants
she can't have there's no way we can
convince anyone we actually like each
other you know I still think about that
night we spent together shut up no I'm
serious no matter how it ended it still
pretty
[Applause]
amazing convincing enough let's do
it honey here he is oh no I'm with Ben
so is it likely just got together or we
saking around let's just be affectionate
Showtime permission to put my left hand
on your right
granted not a magic
lamp hey little guy God damn it see you
tonight we have to kick it up a notch
right nice touch nice
friend oh no no it's going to be when
are you ever going to learn it it's
fine Titanic me are they watching are
they doing Titanic they're gone show's
over oh my
god do you have a mo or something on
your but no
what the what the what the one might be
in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what did we miss what did we miss
it it's
[Music]
fine our little girls growing up so fast
and things couldn't be
better what is
that okay let's clear it all out it's
demo
day demo w what's happening who are you
people what's going
on wait wait you can't wo hey hey what
are you doing all right this is awesome
that with
what orange who made the console orange
do I look orange I didn't touch it
orange is not my color not
me hello oh my gosh I'm anxiety where
can I put my stuff a new emotion wow oh
I'm sorry we wanted to make such a good
first impression what do you mean
[Music]
we ever since I was a child people said
my family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing could
ever hurt
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please
David Carrie I want you to join your
brothers in the ring yes sir I love that
now we all know Carrie's my favorite
then Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change what do you
want in life Kevin Eric more ribs I want
to be with my family you know be with my
brothers what do you like to do with
your brothers
hry and
[Music]
David together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that were passed down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron claw to
you so what do you think like we're a
lot I love your family Kevin
you going to be an uncle yes sir oh man
that makes me so happy I talk to you
about something M Dad's too tough on us
you got to say something maybe that's
what your brothers are for you feel that
you feel that that's
pressure May you're pushing too hard I'm
fine GI seriously I'm just
sick God I'm scared man all my had of
control was a terrible accident I should
have stopped him I needed to think about
my family your job is to wrestle live up
to that deal where we are
through I look out for him I just love
being out there with you guys it's the
only thing that matters to me the will
forever be the greatest family in the
history of
[Applause]
wrest I'm not an enforcer I'm more like
a um a
fixer
exactly I have to convince a certain
person that the buddy in that trunk out
there is indeed Rolo something happened
to his
face what the it's Miss along with the
rest of his
head betrayal is a funny thing it's very
naturous to catch you
unaware you ever heard of ring door bell
we're under
attack stance
gone and you should be too I've always
heard one rule shall be good to the
people who were good to you be good to
yourself Charlie and get as far away
from here as you
can you turned on your own you ought to
get out of buuy char that's what
everyone keeps telling
me that 50 Grand could really change
things for me I'm going with it without
[Music]
you ask Charlie I got more men than you
got bullets bullets are easy to
get what do you want you not breathing
and how you going to do that I'm doing
it you know you really ought to start
thinking about an Exit Plan what are you
waiting
for pull the trigger
Charlie
[Music]
you're in over your
head I don't like
loose he was my second best guy I'm
looking forward to meeting number
one for
long
[Applause]
my son never show
Mercy they are
pray we are
predators Bo your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind you know my
business
yes power is about
strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening shoot
shoot he's weak like his mother leave
him
what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this
Hunter they say he uses a connection
with animals to track his
prey once you're on his
list there's only one way off there six
of us and only one of you there's six of
you
[Music]
now why do you hunt my father puts evil
into the
world I take it
[Music]
out I think you have some kind of Honor
you are exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a
trophy we're
murderers isn't that what he taught
us you don't get to do that to me
anymore Mr
tlin Mr
tlin where's Mr tlin oh you're standing
in
him you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out
now
there is an animal in
aanas don't you want to know why they
call me the
Rhino this world is beyond
cruelty you've been fighting the hinin
for decades my family family has been
fighting them for
centuries they were
massacred alongside my father my father
didn't believe in
Revenge we believe in fman only me fight
beside
you
reload he said that I got
that than
I won't be fighting for him I'm fighting
for my
[Music]
people you young
pop you believe in
Paul there are
signs the prophet why is that a bad
thing use
it because all my Visions lead to
horror
because you lose control because I gain
it Johnny do you believe in
me Paul the trades is still
alive deal with this
Prophet show me who you
are
your
father was a weak
man ru's back from the
dead now do what must be
done we gave them something to hope for
that's not
hope got
it I will love you as long as I
breathe this this prophecy is how they
enslave
us it's not a prophecy it's a story I
don't care what you believe I
believe I am PA Diva
tradies Duke of
baracus
ad he who can destroy thing has the real
control with
[Music]
it you're a blessing used to Clay this
place was crab grass and weeds and you
brought it back to
life Mrs Parker and I with friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of me I just got a
message saying that there's a problem
with my computer yes ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three one two
three there I did it for
you now take it I'm going to burn this
place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have wars for
these things until they fail then you
have me
down my fingers they cut them off what
the bro don't
move
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scan the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem got damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming to a street
through the back entrance I figured i'
give the firefighters a break somebody
detain this
guy we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
p
honey it's flammable as who
knew how does it feel being back good I
had such good memories here maybe my
happy place can be our happy place we
left you all alone down here it was just
my
I'm playing a new game with chy the
scavenger hunt list that's fun chy says
you're not allowed to play with us oh
because you left him I need something
happy something
happy G I thought bugs freaked you out
if I can finish my list try will take me
on a trip to the place he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice
a but it was my
imagin you've been spending time with a
new
[Music]
friend he asked you to do something that
hurt you that was part of the game does
that seem like a game a good friend
would want to play maybe we shouldn't
play together anymore chy maybe we
shouldn't be friends no no no no
no
Alice Alice Alice Alice Alice
Alice she's lost but we're going to find
her every culture has entities that
tether to the young we call them
imaginary
friends you are always saying with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes enraged
just he says he's right behind
you just
imagin can I hang out with your
imaginary friend he's not
imaginary and he's not your
[Applause]
friend
oh look what the Cat Dragged In good
afternoon
e how's your day Dad it was a day just
another day my day was a doozy it's one
of those days you never
forget listen up this young lady is our
new prison
psychologist she may be easy on the eyes
but I assure you she is very
smart I'm Rebecca I
know I don't think I caught your
name
oopsie nasty habit that's why I like it
I live a little differently than most
people they probably scared to you
prison is not place for a young lady you
got a big life ahead of you I'm sure I'm
just kind of average I think you really
think you're a normal
person I bet you have brilliant
dreams Al may I confide in you people
are so ashamed of their
desires I have my own ideas kind of
ideas you can never tell anyone do you
understand promise me
okay that will make you
crazy that will make you
kill can imagine you with a knife can
you imagine me with a
gun that's very good eileene yeah I can
see
it you're different these
days almost interesting secrets and lies
some things are so
Twisted the only way I ask for someone
to
[Music]
die that was a great
trick hi baby boy talking to the fishies
you and me son we're different special
we're connected to the land and the sea
I can't wait to introduce you to all the
majestic creatures on our planet show
you how awesome this world can
be yeah you and
me I'm going to kill
[Music]
Aquaman even if I have to make a deal
with the devil to do
it free me from my PR and all my power
will be yours the key to this prison is
the Royal bloodline
itself he needs us we're The End Of The
Bloodline no we're
not
yeah man took
junior he must be
stopped I'm coming for
you destroy everything he holds de
You Want Blood come get
[Applause]
it there's a young
man I talk to him I wish I was with
[Music]
you that's really weird Lisa
oh
[Music]
my I'm the
greatest God
created Taffy says it's a waste of time
to try and fix up way it's better just
accept a guy fls that's so
[Music]
cute I can't do that
not until we bury the
[Music]
body I can't be
saved and in the next life they remember
me remember
me you
remember
really hope this goth phase in
[Music]
soon I certainly hope you dance as well
as you
dress there's only one way to find
[Music]
out you and I we're not so different
agent
Ary it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother H it's called a
copout whoa hey there's a cat in there
oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
author of ARG series Ellie Conway I am
such a fan oh yeah what does it you do
Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this
book come on W
[Music]
who are these people real life spies why
would they care about me because you're
a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked the
hornet nest you didn't even know existed
I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next chapter
toab God I hate that
[Music]
cat it's time for you to meet the real
agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh oh my
[Music]
God
GL
and
[Music]
child
Santa
[Music]
how did you come to write this book what
really struck me was that too few books
were about my people where are our
stories where's our representation would
you give us the pleasure of reading an
excerpt yo Shira girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you Monk your books are good but they're
not popular editors they want a black
book they have a black book I'm black
and it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they publish look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses in it
I be standing outside in the night dead
beat dads rappers crack you said you
wanted black stuff that's black right I
see what you're
doing we sold your book no we believe Mr
Lee has written a bestseller it's a joke
the most lucrative joke you've ever told
now is stag a sudonym yeah Mr Lee can't
use his real name is this based on your
actual life
yeah you think some ass college
boy can come up with that no no no
I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that not me they ran
300,000 copies your books Chang people's
lives they're offering $4 million for
movie rights yes the Dumber I behave the
Richer I
get this has gone too far stag arly is
still on the run from authorities you
haven't done anything it's not like they
can arrest
you it is wish I could go back to not
selling books is it bad to cater to
people's taste people want to love you
Monk you should let them love all of you
there's already so much Buzz because of
the movie deal Michael beat Jordan in
circling we want to put him on the cover
in one of those um scarves I guess you
would call them tied around his head a
doag doag that's it dag in a tank top
with the muscle showing something called
the fire
department
we're thinking we can get it out in h
for
J this is
Bella Bella this is Mr mandles hello
[Music]
Bella she's an experiment good evening
her brain and her body are not quite
synchronized but she's progressing at an
accelerated
[Music]
piece tell me where did she come from I
shall for it is a happy
[Music]
day I am Bella Baxter and there is a
world to enjoy circumnavigate it is the
goal of all to progress grow a woman
plotting her course to Freedom how
delightful
[Music]
barah
ohow
for
[Music]
foreign
la
[Music]
here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
Dan what is this place we are completely
lost was your
mother that is not your
mother we're trying to get to Jamaica it
seems
simp don't worry ch's got you so listen
Chum what did you just call me sorry I
thought your name was Chum yeah chump
yeah that's my name what right so listen
chump what did you just call me I'm
sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
what
[Music]
this isn't about migration it's about
Adventure w w
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that dange what's
dange it's you with laange on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and
we when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this crazy
wonderful
[Music]
Adventure you're so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm
kidding where am
I
huh go go
[Music]
go illumination legendary villain is
back in an allnew short you wouldn't
happen to know how to get out of here
would you bye MO
[Music]
no no no no don't miss Moon only in
theaters with migration this Christmas
there's a whole world we've been missing
out on what is that
do aange it's you with larange on top
migration plus Vector rated
PG mommy how was Nebraska it was
[Music]
um
the
usual Mr bracket can you tell us what
happened that night at the hotel it was
our anniversary so we wanted to go out I
won't be me you won't be you just two
strangers meeting in a
bar tomorrow
night I'm Jack Alice do you and your
wife roleplay often what exactly is this
about do you know this man no Jack Bob
Bob Jack pleasure he just talked for 5
minutes to all the victims of her charms
and then he
left the one and only hey where are you
I'll be right
back the wife's real name is Anna Peller
wanted for contract killings across
several
continents I'm
sorry
what they told me what you are my wife
is an assassin
this is a lot you kill people it's over
I never wanted to lie to you I just want
a normal life that I have a family to
protect you're my wife I am coming to
help do not come here do you hear me do
not come
here I love you and I love our family we
can get through this we are concerned
about your wife and the safety of your
family she kills me this one
I told you I need out I'll bring the
whole world down on your
[Music]
heads I love you I have to go to work
now though
okay
now killing is bad like unacceptably bad
I know I know I'm done done I
swear
silent
nightly night what's up
roomie get ready it's Christmas Eve have
you been good last year not exactly
naughty but definitely gross for the
naughtiest have I ever shed you
wrong a bunch of times nicest what could
be better than being snowed in with your
family for the
holidays Limpus I think my fre might
have frost bite do not make eye contact
Christmas ever read about this family
they got Snowden and to survive they had
to eat each
other streaming on Disney plus Del
friendo is one of Santa's most important
Scouts it's
alive Ry come on Diary of a Wimpy Kid
Christmas Cabin Fever streaming on
Disney
plus there's some moment in life you
never
[Applause]
forget the Depression hit everyone hard
no jobs no food we were broke looks like
you still owe a balance on this
semester so I was that about making some
money yeah the Rowan team you're R you
get a part-time job included she place
to live a man crew is most difficult
team sport in the
world the average human body is just not
meant for such things most of you will
not be chosen beautiful speech
coach you're announcing the team today
are you going to make it we rode out of
need come on boys the need to stay in
school the need to eat to sleep we got
to keep these right long as we stay on
the team Washington Huskies coach is
bringing an inexperienced vat to
competition they said we couldn't
compete with the rich of school for the
nation the Washington boat has taken the
lead Washington has done it I got 9
seconds under the course record Olympic
year this year Olympic GE I didn't
realize that bunch of kids load like no
one else that's ever come through here
everybody else tires it just get
stronger we have it both and I believe
could qualify for an Olympic spot hope
you know what you're
doing they said we couldn't beat the
Germans we got to beat those other
schools first but coach says we had a
shot maybe we can roll as a team if you
guys don't get yourselves figured out
you're not racing at all boys that boat
s i God but they didn't understand who
we were the show was in this
book I don't believe what I'm
[Applause]
seeing best they
connect sweating
pain what is worth I'm proud of you boys
inspiring uh you missed the part where I
told him not to tip over and a wall R
for your country yeah Ro for each other
for all the people who never believed in
you as one as
[Music]
one show starts in 1
minute let's all go to the lobby let's
all go to the lobby
let all to the lob
[Music]
get someone is killing my
children someone help on uprooting life
in Fairwood as we know and making us
forget who we are where we've come
from now right
now the
get and now on with the
[Music]
show